You know how when you hear that something
costs government $800 billion, it can be kind
of hard to really make that number practical.
It's such a big number, hard to make coherent
sort of practical sense of it.
And the same is true for the number of lies
that Donald Trump has told over 928 days in
office, which was as of August 5th about a
week ago, Donald Trump has told 12,019 lies.
This is the latest tally from the Washington
Post's analysis.
This is about 13 lies per day over the entire
presidency.
Now, as we've become accustomed to the Washington
Post doesn't want to call them lies, they
call them false or misleading claims.
And I've talked a little bit about the possible
legal repercussions of actually using the
word lie, but they are lies.
And Donald Trump lately is lying even more.
The average for the presidency is 13 lies
per day, but since April of this year, it's
been 20 lies per day.
As I earlier, the lies are often about immigration.
They've also been about the economy, about
trade, about Russia.
And I do agree that this is a problem.
Donald Trump either can't or won't tell the
truth, but for me the real issue is the sort
of quality and outrageous and audacious nature
of the lies rather than just the quantity
of lies.
The quantity is shocking, but Donald Trump
has basically skated free from his lies.
And a big reason for that is that his followers
will rationalize the lies away with something
like, oh, all politicians lie.
But they believe that even though Donald Trump
lies, just like any other politician, Trump
has the right ideas and he's doing the right
things, and it leads to zero accountability,
no impact, no effect, no consequences.
Now, I want to believe that independent and
centrist voters do care about the lying and
that therefore, when we finally have a democratic
nominee, the Democratic nominee needs to be
equipped to call Trump out on the lies during
the general election debates or the Democratic
nominee is simply going to have no chance.
I know that we've talked about cognitive decline
and that's a good conversation to have about
Trump, but there's actually a much more obvious
condition, a personality disorder, narcissistic
personality disorder, and this may make it
difficult for the eventual Democratic nominee
to really effectively call Trump out on his
lies.
At first, let's just look at the uh, criteria
for narcissistic personality disorder, which
requires at least five of the following nine,
a grandiose sense of self importance.
That's absolutely something Trump has a preoccupation
with fantasies of unlimited success, power,
brilliance, beauty or ideal love.
Trump certainly has that.
A belief that he or she is special and unique
and can only be understood by or should associate
with other special or high status people or
institutions.
100% the need for excessive admiration, obviously,
I mean, it's almost like describing Trump,
a sense of entitlement, of course, interpersonally,
exploitive behavior.
Yes, a lack of empathy, obviously envy of
others or a belief that others are envious
of him or her.
110% a demonstration of arrogant and haughty
behaviors or attitudes.
Trump hits nine out of nine and only five
of these are required a criteria for a diagnosis
of narcissistic personality disorder.
So this is what we have.
It's pretty clear Trump, his entire life has
been of the mindset that he just needs to
say whatever will get him through the next
30 seconds and it'll all get cleaned up later,
usually by somebody else.
So I think that the idea of just having a
democratic nominee that will call Trump out
about his lies during the debates is not going
to be as much of an easy win as some people
might imagine.
Trump is good at one thing, which is surviving
the next 30 seconds.
And if Donald Trump can survive the next 30
seconds and then the 30 seconds after that
and then the 30 seconds after that during
the debate, uh, that may be enough to keep
him from losing his supporters, his core supporters,
because he's able to just save face and get
out of the debate.
When you're president.
The lies are a major problem for the economy.
They're a major problem for our relationships
with other countries.
But Donald Trump's approach is going to continue
to be the same and it is one of surviving
the next 30 seconds, say whatever you can
to get through the next minute and then deal
with the repercussions on the back end often
with even more lies.
So this is something that is going to be an
issue during the debates.
I think it's going to be more difficult than
some might imagine for the Democratic candidate
to actually hurt Trump with.
And speaking of the general election debates,
will any network hosting the general debates
have the testicular fortitude, for lack of
a better term, to call out Trump every time
that he lies and call out the Democratic candidate
for lies as well, by all means.
But will they have the bravado and the strength
to face the critiques that they have it in
for Trump so to speak?
Or will they simply call out?
That is not true, Mr President, what you just
said is untrue.
It's a an easy moral decision for me, but
I can bet you that the networks are going
to find it a much more difficult decision
to make and they probably will not call out
Donald Trump's lies during the general election
debates.
Let me know what you think.
Makes sure you are following the David Pakman
show on
twitch at twitch.tv/david Pacman.
I will be screaming at this evening at 6:30
PM eastern time and I hope you'll join me
there.